hello welcome to so you're playing
Prince panic this is I am really Hendrix
from the Netherlands is the Kings Indian
player I wasn't I wasn't totally sure
what he does so I go for my page 3 line
yeah I think here white can go but
should be two on orgy for both this is
possible let's play G Ford's with more
with sharp of course their queen 85 is
the idea so maybe maybe I'll push it
away him then h 1 yeah maybe night h5 is
this is an idea this is a 93 check I
don't think so another move a 3 is too
annoying I have to react to it before
was an alternative but don't think this
is bad
yes we have to do it i think i'm going
to put the King on g2
my idea is to if possible play Bishop g4
and after after a trade down I get on
the H file ok I think I'm capturing this
now he's got quite a bit of pieces on
the queenside but it is not that clear
what they are doing currently I have it
hmm protected quite well I have to be a
little bit cautious see about playing
the specialty formal as 93 and then
possibly night a form will them young
activate black's pieces quite a bit
Jim not easy one funny ideas to play
like rook edge for Queen age one queen
age 20 gauge one triple on the edge file
this is not that easy to count them now
he's taking a long time the thing is
it's absolutely not so clear what black
should do him yeah maybe he wants to I'm
shooting for this now this is funny idea
that I mentioned let's see it's very
crude but one problem is if he takes on
d5 he also has to reckon with Knight
takes d5 and all of a sudden the night
is involved as well yeah he needs to he
need to do something drastic but
currently well let me let me think about
this for a moment here I can already win
material and I wonder if I should do
that I think I I think I'll do not
actually it it's not so much the
material that I'm that I'm after but the
c-4 square that looks tempting and the
problem is that default f4 is weak is
mostly exploitable by a night which is
not which is not getting there at the
moment so let's take this
yeah means is also it has to give an
enormous amount of material now it's
actually two exchanges if I just want to
take stuff edgy five is hanging but I
don't see the issue at the moment I can
go china there's no threat just a full
rook
black resign yeah but was it was really
bad out of the opening I'm not quite
sure we had a problem was but the
position got fantastic four white really
really quickly there's h4 I know I just
play the normal move sim the engine
wants to play a five striving for some
kind of counter play and maybe this is
the right way to do it I mean here I
have my doubts where's blacks
counterplay I don't see the counter play
computers agrees that gives wider very
big advantage already maybe still some
f1 I don't know this is this is just
very one-sided it took a long time here
for the rupee aid but what what are you
doing yes like you can take but this is
giving me additional possibilities not
that I play Knights you forward in
general yeah it's free it's free in the
square and currently those pieces they
don't do much can do this on them but
can just take the pawn Knight a form
yeah this is never enough and now I was
going for that that mentioned plan is
actually winning Queen age 1 is plus 5
yeah it is that is like two loaves look
at queen age to Luke h1 and blankets is
resigning the game yeah I did it is over
it is over Luke age seven is actually
stronger here going for the maid no but
okay I think I what I did isn't bad it
just takes big cam big amount material
check just the rook for no compensation
basically yeah the marker gone of
variation the h3
variation um continues to be a problem
for black it's difficult to play okay
thanks for watching